ils étaient 24 dans les années 90 ils ne
sont plus que onze aujourd'hui à plaisir
comme dans beaucoup d'autres villes on
manque de médecins un constat établi par
les premiers intéressés avec la commune
j'ai même le maire qui m'a invité pour
présenter pour montrer pourquoi les
médecins ne voulais pas faire ça l'est
pourquoi on avait du mal à retrouver des
médecins les médecins préfèrent avoir
plus de repos et moins travaillé depuis
les 35 heures on a vu ça les conditions
de travail alors à un cliché curité
sociale une heure de travail pour faire
des papiers qui sert pratiquement à rien
on fait le doublé comme ça après quatre
ans de recherche cet ancien médecin n'a
trouvé aucun repreneur à la suite de son
départ à la retraite la commune de
plaisir souhaitent se mobiliser en
faveur d'un retour des médecins sur son
territoire la ville travaille
actuellement à la création d'une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire qui serait
complètement prise en charge au niveau
de l'investissement par les départements
et qui accompagnerait pendant trois ans
au niveau du fonctionnement avec les
secrétaires médicales donc on va déjà
expliquer tout ça aux médecins et aux
pharmaciens en sachant que nous avons
aussi une maison médicale privée qui va
ouvrir un côté je dirais d'art du centre
commercial de façon à ce que là aussi il
y ait une série de médecins qui arrivent
et d'après ce qu'on m'a dit il y aurait
deux médecins généralistes war 3 qui
viendrait dans cette maison médicale
privée un plan d'action mis en place
avec les pharmaciens des médecins et
saint quentin en yvelines un engagement
que la commune souhaite faire connaître
aux habitants une campagne d'information
sera lancée début 2010 8